donc voilà c'est ce qu'on fait de plus
en plus dorénavant on protège de culture
avec des des postes électriques voilà
donc là c'est un champ de blé qui a été
semé suite derrière un champ de maïs
donc faut savoir que c'est ce que
sanglier préfère venir chercher les
équipes maïs qui restent dans les sur
les semis de céréales de blé notamment
cette agriculteur est installé aux
portes de Sully-sur-Loire dans une
plaine éloignée de toute forêts il est
éleveur laitier dispose de 180 hectares
de terre avec des céréales et des
pâturages il y a 10 ans les sangliers
étaient quasi inexistants ici
ça fait trois ans ici qu'on est qu'on
est un petit peu embêté par les
sangliers et là depuis deux ans c'est
devenu un peu c'est devenu exponentiel
de tirer parce que les dégâts sont
croissants on va voisiner les entre 15
et 18000 euros de dégâts voilà bonjour
Céline alors
ça c'est les dossiers qui sont en
attente de règlement ou régler ça c'est
des dossiers qui sont réglés les dégâts
de sanglier sont devenus tellement
massifs dans le Loiret que la fédération
départementale des chasseurs est en
alerte rouge pour la seule année
2022.600 dossiers d'indemnisation ont
été traités dans ce bureau ils sont
parfois accompagnés de très belles
photos de quadrupède ce prélassant dans
des champs de blé ou de maïs la
fédération de chasse n'est plus très
sensible à la poésie de ces images elle
qui assume en raison d'une loi datant du
26 juillet 2000 l'intégralité de
l'indemnisation de ces dégâts
la fracture globale donc du 1er juillet
2021 au 30 juin 2022 2008 alors que les
années précédentes ont tourné un million
cinq un million 8 voilà là 2008 ça
devient c'est si on peut plus on est au
bout du bout là
ça a commencé à être fini ici en fait
juste sur le bord de route l'Office
français de la biodiversité
héritier de l'Office national de la
chasse et le témoin privilégié de la
prolifération des sangliers il effectue
chaque année une estimation des
populations aujourd'hui à peu près
800.000 sangliers en France en région
Centre-Val de Loire on atteint des
tableaux de chasse qui est l'estimation
qu'on a des populations qui est pas
littéral des populations qui avoisinent
95.000 sangliers alors qu'on était il y
a une dizaine d'années à 49 000
sangliers à peu près dans notre région
face à cette explosion démographique
tous les acteurs demandent au chasseur
de tuer plus de sangliers il faut
notamment prélever des femelles et des
jeunes mâles auparavant préservés une
intensification des prélèvements devenus
urgentes car une nouvelle menace se
précise il faut pas oublier que
lorsqu'on atteint des niveaux très
importants de population de
densification des animaux c'est propice
à l'émergence de certaines épisodes
aussi je pense à l'apexine africaine qui
sévit pas loin de nos frontières ou à la
une maladie de jeski qu'on rencontre
notre région et ça c'est un peu un
spectre qui se profile à l'horizon et
qu'il faut absolument éviter un scénario
que certains estiment inéluctables tant
les populations de sanglier semblent
aujourd'hui hors de contrôle une
surpopulation qui a aussi des
conséquences sur la sécurité routière
les collisions de grands animaux très
majoritairement de sangliers
représentent plus de 60 000 accidents
chaque année en France